merci beaucoup de répondre à mes
questions 12 4 millions de personnes
encore aujourd'hui au chômage partiel
vous estimez que c'est on est arrivé à
un certain sens sur ce chômage partiel
est ce que vous assumez de vouloir
réduire ses aides de l'état sur le
chômage partiel parce que eh bien cela
coûte trop cher alors les 12 millions
400 mille salariés les 1 million
d'entreprises qui sont protégés par le
chômage partiel
c'est le cumul de tous les demandes
depuis début de puis le début ce qu'on
constate c'est qu'il ya un peu moins
aujourd'hui de demandes on est à onze
millions quelque donc ça commençait très
légèrement a signifié que le retour au
travail existe et je pense qu'on va
réserver une semaine ça va augmenter
progressivement
la priorité c'est que tous ceux qui
étaient au chômage partiel puissent
retrouver leur contrat de travail et
avoir un emploi donc à fur et à mesure
que la reprise de l'activité se fait
évidemment il ya moins de personnes qui
voient au chômage partiel dans les
semaines qui viennent il ya beaucoup de
signes de reprise je suis confiante là
dessus est ce qu'il faudrait développer
la prise en charge de l'état sur a créé
par celle ci étant maintenant et dans
les périodes post confinement on a
réouvert les commerces notamment qui
rouvre pour beaucoup je crois qu'on peut
tous le constater depuis lundi et donc
il est logique de cette phase là que on
a fasse évoluer les règles on a je pense
cette eau peut être fier qu en france on
a eu un chômage partiel massif
pendant la première période ou pour
protéger les entreprises qu'elles
gardent leurs compétences protéger les
salariés qui gardent leur contrat de
travail
tout ça c'est 12 millions de personnes
dont le salaire a été payée par l'état
il est logique avec la reprise que
progressivement les entreprises prennent
une part et qu'il y ait un reste à
charge ou line partie de ce salaire
qu'ils soient pris en charge par les
entreprises qui vont avoir une partie de
leurs salariés en contrat de travail
normale si je dirais une partie au
chômage partiel
est ce que vous craignez bien sûr le
risque c'est aussi bien le risque du
chômage que ces entreprises et bien
elles fassent des plans de licenciement
si elles doivent et bien intervenir plus
dans ce chômage partiel et une fois des
relations sont au sport ces termes là
pour les secteurs qui peuvent pas
repartir pour l'instant parce qu'il ya
une interdiction administrative comme
les bars et les restaurants bien sûr le
taux de prise en charge restera à 100%
et là où il ya une exploitation il ya
une production
on a réouvert un chantier une usine une
activité un commerce il y à une
exploitation économique et donc il y a
une capacité productive
donc dans ce cadre là c'est normal qu'il
ya une contribution qui sera pas
majoritaires mais une contribution des
entreprises pour accompagner la reprise
progressive en je crois que c'est
logique et que tout le monde le comprend
une dernière question muriel pénicaud
vous êtes favorable en tout cas vous
avez dit que vous étiez plutôt pour hier
la proposition de certains députés de la
république en marge de donner des congés
aux soignants alors par quel mécanisme
cela peut-il se faire et est ce que vous
iriez jusqu'à et bien être favorable à
la proposition de loi lr2 maximino qui a
déposé un texte en ce sens le 22 mars
dernier
il ya des députés qui effectivement
m'ont interpellé hier en demandant si au
nom du gouvernement était favorable au
fait que des salariés à titre volontaire
bien sûr puisse consacrer certains de
leurs jours de rtt ou jours de repos à
payer à la place des chèques vacances
pour les soignants écoutez chaque fois
qu'il ya initiatives de solidarité que
ce soit sur le terrain quand on en voit
tous les jours partout sur le territoire
où que ce soit au niveau des
parlementaires je crois qu'il faut
encourager ces initiatives
donc j'attends leurs propositions c'est
eux qui vont élaborer ce projet nous en
parlerons pour mettre ça en exécution il
faut encourager notre solidarité aux
marches la première demain c'est à eux
de discuter entre eux c'est d'abord une
initiative parlementaire et ensuite le
gouvernement répondra